what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so the story of war 'the war is actually
really interesting and it's really
really cool because this gives us a
version of thor that we haven't
necessarily seen before but a lot of
this is really just sort of up to
interpretation in a lot of ways - and
the reason i say that is because we
covered Thor's the other day and we
basically sat down and we looked at this
idea of the hammer that belonged to
ultimate four and what it was that
happened to the hammer now the weird
thing about this is that over the years
ultimate Thor's hammer had kind of
received this this sort of bouncing
around in the sense that it was
destroyed it was remade different things
like that there was one point where he
actually got this sort of you know
traditional mule near that we see in the
main Marvel Universe not the exact same
one but something similar to it but the
idea was that in the Thor's storyline
from secret wars that ultimate Thor was
one of these individuals who served as
doctor dooms Police Force basically and
what had happened was that in this
massive brawl among these different
versions of Thor that the ultimate
hammer had left the secret wars universe
and was either transported throughout
all space and time or just transported
into the past or something along those
lines but ended up in Asgard it
basically broke through the dimensional
barriers and ended up in this pocket
dimension of Asgard now in truth that
should not have been allowed to happen
the entire basis behind secret wars was
that all conceivable universes and all
spaces dimensions the whole you know all
that stuff those were all destroyed in
the collapse of the multiverse
everything was gone and the only chunk
of existence that was left was
battleworld so again it kind of fit into
a weird situation but this gives us an
update in terms of what's going on in
the sense of what this hammers capable
of and what it can do now what did he
keep in mind is there are two schools of
thought that are currently floating
around right now in terms of the nature
of this hammer the school of thought
that I ascribed to you is that it's the
hammer that originally belonged to
ultimate Thor but there is a school of
thought that also believes that this
hammer was used by ultimate Thor but was
actually forged by Doctor Doom during
the events of battle world as far as I'm
aware were not explicitly told if that's
true in terms of which version of the
hammer this is all we know is that it's
a hammer that does not have a worthiness
enchantment and as we go through this
will actually find out this hammer is
almost identical in terms of what it can
do to the actual hammer of Thor but the
other half of this is that for those of
you guys who are just now joining us we
are basically in the midst of what's
called the war vroom
and the idea here is that this is
essentially a being named Malekith the
accursed trying to conquer all things in
existence that's basically what it is
now Malekith the accursed is a really
cool villain he's had the casket of
ancient winters but he's always been
this sort of background villain Malekith
was always around there somewhere in
some form or fashion what war of the
realms does is it actually brings him to
full focus and essentially what do you
been doing is travelling around the
various realms of Asgard and recruiting
different people to his cause initially
it was the frost giants then it became
the trolls and it became all these
different groups who rallied to Malekith
knowing that Malekith probably had the
wherewithal to win the conflict and the
reason for that is the other half of the
equation because while Malekith was
traveling around and trying to conquer
everything everybody looked to Asgard as
the people who would save them the
problem is that Asgard had a lot of
inner turmoil because there was this
huge civil war going on in terms of
whether or not Jane Foster was actually
Thor and so because that it led to like
Odin taking sides against Jane Foster it
led to Odin's wife Freya going on the
side of Jane Foster and it led to this
great big huge conflict and so because
of this it allowed Malekith the accursed
to begin the process of going through
and just conquering all these different
realms with almost no one to stand in
his way now in this instance what this
does is it picks up with the aftermath
of the death of the light elves which
are one of the various race of elves
that exist within the Asgardian mythos
and the idea was that the the light owls
are one of the first groups that
Malekith took out just because the
lydell's
and the dark elves are mortal enemies
and so with the lydell's being pushed to
the brink of extinction
what they had done is they had taken up
residence with the dwarves now the
dwarves are extremely important in
Asgardian mythos the reason for this is
because of the fact that the dwarves are
basically the greatest craftsmen and all
of the Asgardian realms they're the ones
that Forge the hammer of Thor now it's
kind of a funny thing here because we
actually pick up with Volstagg with Ross
Solomon and with the queen of the
lighthouse and the cool thing about this
is that Roz Solomon was originally a
character who was introduced as just
this random shield Asian and it was
actually this girl who had this desire
to basically go on a date with Thor
which he granted to her Odin's son went
on a date with Ross Solomon but ever
since then she's always been kind of
this recurring supporting character but
she is quite versed in the Asgardian
mythos just because of the fact
travelled around and seen a lot of these
different things but Volks tagged
himself is also a really kindly guy
who's also like a force to be reckoned
with because in truth he's one of the
Warriors three that exists inside of the
main Marvel Universe and he's one of the
most capable warriors that exists out
there one of the bravest men around the
problem with the war of Realms is that
it takes its toll in every conceivable
way physically because of the loss of
life because people who have to fight
over and over and over again simply to
just survive but it also takes a
psychological toll and the reason for
this is because Volstagg of course
spending time with these these light elf
children is basically met with the
arrival of the forces of Surtur that
immediately show up in the land of the
dwarfs and start tearing everything to
pieces the problem with this is that the
parents of these light elves are all
killed the parents of these children are
all totally destroyed and it leaves
Volstagg in a situation where he's just
kind of required to take care of them as
best he can and sort of go through there
and call it a day the issue is that as
he makes his way through there and as
these forces officer der basically begin
to emerge and continue wreaking all this
havoc they end up killing the kids now
this is when this psychological break
happens in the mind of Volstagg while he
has seen a multitude of conflicts on
multitude of battles and a multitude of
wars it's one thing to basically fight
against an enemy to eliminate them in
their entirety and it's another to stand
there and be helpless in the face of
loss of life and that's why this is so
huge is because he literally just
experiences this sort of psychic break I
mean it just cracks him almost in two
and so in response to this he does the
only thing he can do he literally seeks
out the ultimate hammer and picks it up
now remember when the ultimate hammer
crash-landed in old Asgard during the
events of Thor's it was basically
safeguarded there was this idea that no
one's gonna pick it up no one's gonna go
and take it no one's gonna use it
because no one really knows how it works
this whole conflict this whole idea of
whether or not Jane Foster is worthy has
thrown into sharp relief the idea that
just because a person picks up the
hammer of Odin does not mean that
everyone in Asgard is going to believe
that person is Thor and so because of
that people do not want to experience
yet another civil war within Asgard
going on at the same time as the first
and so what they ended up doing was say
this is all hands off now of course the
idea was that Odin son himself will be
the one who would maintain the hammer
the problem with this is that when Jane
Foster
to him and basically said hey I am
currently Thor I'm the one who was able
to pick up your hammer it was sort of a
betrayal for Odin son in the sense that
their relationship had gone back you
know both his friends and even his
people who were an item at one time it
had gone back for quite some time and
for Odin son it was this idea that if
Jane Foster was going to become the new
Thor the very least she could do is tell
him if only out of just respect for the
legacy that he carried the fact that she
hid it means there's a lack of trust
there and in that belief of a lack of
trust
Odin's son just kind of looked at her
with a skewed eye and so again this
creates this whole huge inner turmoil
because with war Thor's showing up he
goes to town and the reason for this is
because he shows up in this camp these
armies of Surtur's forces and just
obliterate I mean is one of the most
spectacular displays of absolute
decimation that I've ever seen but
notice this this is not full stag in his
traditional sense he's kindly he's more
of a jovial character as opposed to like
this battle-hardened everything has to
die kind of character but the other half
of this is that his path of destruction
is being monitored by a more of the
enchantress and yulik king of the trolls
now these are two of the most powerful
beings in all of Asgard trying to take
out war Thor none of it works now what
this does is this hits home at the
nature of the ultimate hammer of Thor in
the Ultimate Universe the hammer was
originally tech based over the course of
the years it almost seemed as though the
hammer was moving up to becoming almost
equivalent to the hammer of Thor and the
main Marvel Universe but it was never on
that level it was basically a tech based
hammer the issue with this is that this
is why I say this seems to ascribe to
the idea that the hammer as it exists
now was forged by Doctor Doom during the
events of battle world when the Thor
Corps was being formed because we
basically ended up seeing a display of
power that we've never seen before the
ability of the hammer to deflect blast
to basically eliminate Magic's in a way
that we hadn't seen it before and so
again that's why it looks as though it's
a hammer forged by Doctor Doom but we're
not explicitly told that that's the case
but regardless of the circumstances even
with him having this hammer whether he
has it or not Volstagg is still a match
for almost anybody out there just
because of how strong he is he almost
kills both enchantress and yulik it's
not until enchantress uses her abilities
and basically summons the black Bifrost
which is to say their own teleportation
system and gets them out of there
she manages to survive the experience
but within Volstagg himself there's a
sort of inner turmoil this idea that he
realizes something's off now what this
all seems to do is hit at home to the
very nature of the hammers themselves
because remember for years and years and
years and years it was this idea that
Thor's hammer was just a hammer
something he picked up and had a
worthiness enchantment magic was somehow
involved and then he was able to do all
kinds of stuff with it he could teleport
he could fly you'd do all manner of
things it wasn't until recent years when
Jason Aaron came back and gave us the
untold origin of Thor's hammer when he
basically established that the hammer of
Thor is basically possessed by this sort
of cosmic storm that was equal in power
to Odin himself Odin was able to
basically channel the storm into a chunk
of uber send it over to the doors have
them crafted into a hammer and then his
son was eventually able to pick it up in
this particular story what seems to be
going on or at least what Jason Aaron is
hitting at is that much like the hammer
of for being sentient this ultimate
hammer is sentient as well but it's
basically sentient with the wrath of a
universe that's long since been
destroyed all that energy and all that
power is channeled directly into the
hammer itself and so what it means is
that it's quite literally dominating
Volstagg and that's why it's such a huge
deal is because in the midst of all this
one thing to keep in mind is that it
also reminds us that Jane Foster is
still dying
one of the things that Jason Aaron
established almost immediately before
Jane Foster ever picked up the hammer in
the first place
is that it was ever going to be a
temporary thing that because of the fact
that she has cancer because she's
basically dying she does undergo
chemotherapy but everytime she becomes
thort it purges the chemotherapy from
her system and so in a sense she might
as well have never had chemotherapy at
all and so the result is that she's
constantly dying of cancer and what
it'll do is it'll eventually get to the
point where she will die altogether and
she will never have the hammer again
she'll be dead but what this does is
this actually transfers us for a second
to a place called Muspelheim the realm
of Surtur the realm of these fire demons
and we actually end up picking up with
his daughter cinder now the crazy thing
about this is that sewer has been dead
for quite some time
Serdar was basically destroyed by Odin
or at least his essence was destroyed by
Odin and so what this did is it allowed
for some measure of a power vacuum
within Muspelheim itself now this vacuum
was filled almost immediately by cinder
but this is the first time we see her
character this is the first time she's
being introduced
Serdar had had a whole bunch of children
over the years she was the first one to
basically prove herself worthy of taking
over her father's role remember
Serdar is this guy who basically has it
out for the Odin and all the Asgardians
and a lot of that's because of the fact
that Odin and his brothers had faced off
against Serdar Odin was responsible for
imprisoning Serdar in earth and so it's
really one of those things where it's
more like a blood vendetta as opposed to
you know some eternal battle that was
always destined to happen or something
along those lines but the idea is that
with Malekith showing up alongside Loki
keep in mind originally Loki was sent to
Malekith by freya to be a spy for the
Asgardians somewhere along the line he
seems to have turned coded and abandoned
his mother's cause taking up his cause
with Malekith but we don't know that for
certain
Loki is very much a wild card in this
story he seems to be an ally but we
don't know for sure but regardless of
the reasoning behind at Malekith running
this sort of council of realms the idea
is to basically make sure that everybody
has their own role to play and to make
sure they're playing their roles
effectively the fire demons are some of
the most formidable beings out there
when they show up and they start
cleansing places those places are gone
but for Malekith is also a very tenuous
situation because if they chose to turn
on him then not only would he be facing
me as guardians he would be facing the
fire demons and so again the goal is to
bear
much make sure that they're playing
their role but what he also does is
essentially show up and say you have a
new Thor on the scene and this new Thor
needs to be taking care of as quickly as
possible because this new Thor was able
to see well handedly take down your
entire army now what this does is it
leads to a battle between war Thor and
cinder and this is something I want to
talk about for a second because this is
interesting to me if this were Serdar
this battle would be over before it even
started when it comes to someone like
Serdar you're talking about a guy who
went toe-to-toe with odin killed Odin
prior to the events of Ragnarok we're
talking about a very capable being
that's out there sort of being out of
the picture his daughter sinner taking
the place she's not on that same level
of power she's capable but she's not on
that level and so what this does is it
gives us a battle between the two but I
don't want you to see this as something
you know with regards to war for being a
lot more powerful than he is not at all
this is not like war Thor fighting sir
the other half of this is that the death
of all these kids keep playing over
constantly in the mind of ol stack and
that's what drives him while the hammer
does not kind of seize control of him
the idea of feeding these images into
his mind time and time again of these
kids dying
continues to push him to the point where
all he wants to do is destroy all he
wants to do is see the death of all
things now because of the fact that
worth work hears nothing about
everything that exists in must behind
what it does is it brings him and it
brings Jane Foster Thor directly into
conflict with one another now the reason
why this happens is because of the fact
that in the mind of Jane Foster
while cinder is a terrible ruler while
cinder is a terrible being you know all
she wants to do is just sort of see the
destruction of the Asgardians the cinder
herself is not a reflection of the
beings within muscled ha there are
innocence there there are young children
who are fire demon children but they are
young children nonetheless they have not
had the chance to actually grow and
adopt their own mindset Jane Foster sees
these kids as basically innocence the
ability to move on and to have their own
lives if real Muspelheim is going to be
free to the control of cinder and the
entire legacy of Surtur that it starts
with the defeat of cinder herself and
then giving the survivors the
opportunity to forge their own paths but
in the eyes of Jane Foster it is not
acceptable to kill kids and so what this
does is it basically brings Jane Foster
and war Thor to this place as this sort
of image
area called the yawning void now what
this does is it basically seems to
indicate this empty space in between
dimensions or maybe where all life
seemed to hail from or something along
those lines the Asgardian depiction of
the origin of all things is a little bit
different from what we're normally used
to in the main Marvel Universe in the
beginning there was only just darkness
that was it and then darkness somehow
gave form to life life gave form to more
life gave formed a planets gave form to
you know stars systems different things
like that but it all started with
absolute darkness and the idea is that
the yawning void is that absolute
darkness is that lack of anything
there's nothing there they're basically
fighting in a space or there is no
concern about you know anybody being in
danger there's no concern about loss of
life or anything along those lines but
the idea is that the fight between the
two of them just starts spreading
through them and it literally tears
through all these different facets of
the realms in the sense that those who
were in the equivalent of hell within
the Asgardian mythos can see this fight
take place you know those who are in
heaven where Angela comes from you can
see this fight taking place it's really
not until Jane Foster takes the ultimate
hammer of Thor that we as the reader
learned that it has been possessing
Volstagg the entire time poisoning his
mind but again is sort of a wild
scenario because once Onan son realizes
that Volstagg is war Thor that Volstagg
is going on this path of tearing things
up initially Odin son tries to reason
with them the problem with this is that
Volstagg seems to be beyond the point of
reason he's literally a mad dog driven
by the only motivation to just see all
things destroyed it's just nothing but
anger and wrath and rage and so it's
kind of cool because it's almost one of
those things music soothes the savage
beast in the sense that Jane Foster
simply puts the hammer down and lets all
pretense go and approaches Volstagg is
just a normal person now this is cool
because this is designed to show Jane
Foster as being effective as not just
Thor but also as Jane Foster the
character in this instance Odin a son
basically just kind of sends the hammer
away he tells the hammer get out of here
he not supposed to be here you know
sends it back to Asgard and that's
really about it but it's this idea that
Malekith continues his campaign of
grabbing all these different armies from
around the Asgardian realm and bringing
them to his cause his next stop is the
realm of heaven his next stop is to
basically step in to the angels
themselves and say become part of my
Council of realms help me
basically conquer everything
and I will restore your rightful place
among the Asgardian landscape but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]